- You want to go with somethin'
kind of more in this family?
Something a little sporty.
- If I wanted to referee a game randomly.
- Well that hurts a little bit.
- Okay.
(upbeat music)
- We've been friends for
probably about four years now.
- And we've been friends for two months.
- Well I've actually gotten a lot of flack
for my wardrobe from this friend.
- My wardrobe would probably
be held together by the staples
of polo shirts, jeans, and t-shirts.
My girlfriend, who's from
California, thought that I was
dressing as a caricature of
someone from the Northeast.
- I grew up in the South,
so I got some southern shit.
- He says I wear like
a lot of baseball tees.
Coincidentally, I'm wearing one right now.
- I would say my style
is like wannabe hipster.
- He's super put together all the time.
- I have considered that
people might like the change
and go, "Hey buddy, really
like the new wardrobe you did
cuz the old stuff was terrible."
- Well there's definitely gonna
be an upgrade and a downgrade.
- I think I'm gonna look snazzy as hell.
- And I think I'm gonna
look like a rockstar.
So we're both in for a treat.
- How do we look?
- Ben looks good.
- I don't know if this pink polo thing is,
it's in public, it's happening.
- Alright, it's day two.
I am wearing Corey's henley
and jacket and with my shoes
on I feel vaguely like Indiana Jones.
- This is atrocious.
Like why would you give this to me?
- I'm about to get to know
him even better than I do
cuz I'm gonna walk a mile
in these argyle socks.
- So I went to try to
schmooze the parking attendant
lady with a little hey, hi,
like a little southern charm.
She was not having it.
I blame the sweater.
- I also got a compliment
about the jacket I was wearing.
It was Ryan's green letterman jacket.
I'm starting to not really notice
that I'm wearing different clothes.
The only thing that I do notice
is that I'm just a lot more comfortable.
- So I just talked to my
cousin and she said that she
doesn't, like she can't tell
the difference between these
clothes and my normal clothes.
- Today I'm rockin' a
windbreaker and a Cubs shirt.
Do you zip it up?
Let's go to a soccer match and just like
fuck some people up afterwards,
you know what I'm sayin'.
- Alright, another day
in Corey's clothing.
I wore it to work today, the
reception was very positive.
Say for one person who asked
if I joined a boy band recently
but I think that's an outlier
and I think this look is a hit.
- The only thing about Kevin's clothes
that I really don't like is this belt.
With this thing, every step
I take, it keeps loosening
and I keep having to like
tighten it like 10 times a day.
- So I feel like kind of a
dick because I made a big deal
about how crappy this sweater is,
but it's actually really
comfortable and warm.
I kind of like it.
- These shorts are awesome.
They're not pretty to look
at, we'll make no bones about
that, but they are comfortable,
they are breezy, they are warm.
- These joggers that I'm wearing,
they're probably the most
comfortable pair of pants
I've ever worn in my life.
I'm gonna be pretty sad to say goodbye
to these clothes at the end of the week.
(upbeat music)
- Nobody noticed I was
dressing differently.
My family and my friends and my cousins
all said yeah, you look the same.
- I kinda had like an identity
crisis cuz I was just like,
people were starting to call me Ryan.
This is kinda weird, I'm not used to
wearing this sort of stuff like everyday.
- Working from a group of
clothes that I've never seen
before, it really made me
sympathize with my girlfriend
because I always like to tease
her a little bit about how
long she takes to select the right outfit.
Now I kind of understand when
you really gotta take a look at it.
- My pants are starting to fall down.
He's got thicker calves and thighs
than me, so maybe that's why.
- So Davis gave me these red shorts.
- The shorts with the shirt, you're
really going for a power move there.
That kind of combo, that's confidence.
- Towards the end of the week, I was
just like maybe I'll invest
in some baseball tees.
- He's got this sweater with
sort of a shawl collar on it.
Someone asked me where I bought that.
And then I had to have the
uncomfortable conversation of
I don't know, I'm wearing
another man's clothes.
Wait, wait, wait, it's
not as weird as you think.
- It's quite lucky that
we're the same size.
- I know right.
- It was super fun.
And now I can wear his clothes.
I could just ask and he'll give
them to me at the drop of a hat.
Which is super great.
- My girlfriend Becky, the
windbreaker that I was so opposed
to, she thought it looked hot.
Windbreakers are in people.
- No, that's not the
message of this video.